Neutron stars are one of the most
extreme things in the universe.
They're like giant Hassam
cause kilometers in diameter.
Unbelievably dense and violent,
but how can something
like this even exist?
The life of a star is dominated by two
forces being in balance its own gravity
and the radiation pressure of it's
fusion reaction. In the core of stars,
hydrogen is fused into helium.
Eventually the hydrogen and the core is
exhausted. If the star is massive enough,
helium is now fused into carbon.
The cause of these massive stars become
layered like onions as heavier and
heavier atomic nuclei build up at the
center. Carbon is fused into neon,
which leads to oxygen,
which leads to silicon.
Eventually the fusion reaction hits iron,
which cannot fuse into another element.
When the fusion stumps,
the radiation pressure drops rapidly.
The star is no longer in balance and if
it's core mass exceeds about 1.4 so the
masses,
a catastrophic collapse takes place.
The outer part of the core reaches
velocities of up to 70,000 kilometers a
second as it collapses towards
the center of the star. Now. Oh,
neither fundamental forces inside an
atom are left to fight the gravitational
collapse.
The quantum mechanical repulsion of
electrons is overcome and electrons and
protons fuse into neutrons packed
as densely as an atomic nucleus.
The outer layers of the star
are catapulted into space
in a violence supernova
explosion,
so now we have a neutron star.
It's masses between one and three sons,
but compressed to an object about 25
kilometers wide and 500,000 times the mass
of earth in this tiny ball that's
roughly the diameter of Manhattan.
It's so dense that one cubic centimeter
of neutron star contains the same mass
as an iron cube,
700 meters across.
That's roughly 1 billion tons.
As massive as Mount Everest in a
space the size of a sugar cube,
neutron star gravity is
pretty impressive too.
If you were to drop an object
from one meter over the surface,
it would hit the star in one microsecond
and accelerate up to 7.2 million
kilometers per hour.
The surface is super flat
with irregularities of five
millimeters maximum with a
super thin atmosphere of hot plasma.
The surface temperature is about 1 million
Kelvin compared to 5,800 Kelvin for
our son.
Let's look inside the neutron star.
The Christ is extremely hard and is
most likely made of an iron atom nuclei
lattice with a sea of
electrons flowing through them.
The closer we get to the the more
neutrons and fewer protons we see until
there's just an incredibly dense
soup of indistinguishable neutrons.
The cause of neutron stars are very,
very wait.
We're not sure what their properties are,
but how closest guess is superfluid
neutron degenerate matter or some kind of
ultra dense quark matter
called quark glue on plasma.
That doesn't make any sense
in the traditional way and
can only exist in such an
ultra extreme environment.
In many ways,
a neutron star is similar
to a giant atom core.
The most important
difference is that Adam,
cause I held together by
strong interaction and
neutron stars by gravity as if
all this wasn't extreme enough. Let's
take a look at a few other properties.
Neutron stars spend very,
very fast young ones
several times per second,
and if there's a poor star
nearby to feed the neutron star,
it can rotate up to several
hundred times per second,
like the object Psr j one
seven four eight two four four,
six and it's bins at approximately
252 million kilometers per hour.
This is so fast that the star
has a rather strange shape.
We call these objects pulse house
because they emit a strong radio signal,
and the magnetic field of a neutron star
is roughly a trillion times stronger
than the magnetic field of earth.
So strong that atoms get bent when
they enter it's influence. Okay.
I think we got the point across.
Neutron stars are so the most extreme,
but also some of the coolest
objects in the universe.
Hopefully we'll one day sends patients
to learn more about them and take some
neat pictures,
but we shouldn't get too close.